miron I got the script I was like
Michael brought this great script when I
was how did this happen and this is one
that long ago and how did these bad
ideas catch on these this idea that you
could hypnotize American movie goers
through mainstream move through
mainstream movies into somehow getting
on board with a communist manifesto and
therefore we should you know strip out
all of the some of the best
screenwriters and them some of the most
mainstream screenwriters who were also
really some of them very patriotic wrote
you know Trumbo wrote thirty seconds
over Tokyo and you know he loved his
country and somehow the idea that people
like him and him were were enemies of a
state and should be expunged you know
how did so it's exactly why I chose to
get involved in this one it's the same
reason for the other ones just to figure
it out because it's it's sort of
tortured not to be able to figure it out
so until you do it's its anxious there's
something heroic about Trumbo but in a
way he was an unlikely an almost
unintentional hero because in truth he
loved his life loved the money that he
made loved his family loved his lake and
he didn't really expect to have to go to
jail for what he was doing because there
was that kind of complicated calculus
with the appeal to the Supreme Court
justices and I remember reading the
script and and turning a page and
reaching that moment when the two
Supreme Court justices died unexpectedly
and I was really fascinated with that
notion of someone who hadn't meant to
risk all and all of a sudden found
himself in the position of being heroic
almost almost by default and deserved it
and and evolved into it but perhaps
didn't where his idealism on his sleeve
and Jays the humanity that he's had in
all of his work I've known Jay a bit and
I and I had watched his work evolve in
particularly the HBO movies and his
comedies are always incredibly humane
there's not a lot of snark or cynicism
in Jays work and it would be so easily
to fall into that or something really
really kind of preachy and what Jay
brought was just this great emotional
connection to the character and a desire
to kind
unravel what was really going on inside
of him and something that would be
entertaining also for for an audience
and not not feel like a history lesson
and and that was a huge issue with this
movie is how do you make it not feel
just like a history lesson and it's an
incredible history lesson and taking
nothing away from that it meant to have
all these other layers and then once we
started working together Jay put his
mark on the script and got us involved
with the Trumbo daughters who at the
time John McNamara had been had not yet
sort of gone into the belly of the beast
with them and that was a complicated
process and the script got richer and
richer and all of a sudden we had
something that it we realized if we
didn't that the challenge of finding an
actor who could represent all of those
different pieces of it the ideas the
passion of it the humanity the humor the
curmudgeonly side of Trumbo because he
was a complicated contradictory
character and and somehow Bryan somehow
there was no one else but Bryan that
could do that and once we thought about
Bryan we did thank God he responded the
way he did because I'm not sure anyone
else could have done it and it was
fortuitous because Bryan was finishing
work on his television series but it
felt like with all the pieces of this
movie that everything kind of came
together at the right time Nicola and
Mitzi Trumbo and also Nancy Asher who is
Chris from Beau's Widow helped
tremendously and they were available to
us and offered their opinions on the
script and a lot of their suggestions
made it into the final draft personally
they were accessible and available and
willing and desirable to help us and I
think I just made an appeal to them that
I I want to see if I can get close to
the essence of who your father was and
the more I did the research on him you
know with a non fictional character you
do have an added risk sense of
responsibility and this being recent
history there is a plethora of audio
tapes and videotapes and a couple books
and and and all his own material to to
glean information from so there was
never a shortage of what to do I I never
wanted to
the danger of this character is to you
know become a caricature and the more I
started watching him and the more
theatrical I realized he was with the
cigarette holder and and he he loved
flowery language and he loved holding
courts he would love sitting right here
right now he would absolutely have loved
it and he likes the exchange of ideas
and I think that's at the core of his
being is that everyone has the right to
exchange those ideas so information was
free-flowing not only among the creative
team but they helped tremendously with
it consultations and and not just for me
but for the other actors curious whether
Kirk Douglas has seen the film and the
reason I'm asking is I was lucky enough
to do a long career interview with him
in my series of the 92nd Street Y a few
years ago and at one point as he was
taking credit for breaking the blacklist
he specifically told the story of how
before announcing it Stanley Kubrick
agreed to take the screenwriting credit
and Kirk Douglas said he was very
uncomfortable with it and he went home
and he saw his dog and he he decided to
call his dog by the wrong name he went
Max and the dog he said didn't answer
and he concluded even a dog knows its
own name and he said that's why the next
day he decided to announce this so you
show Kirk Douglas and Otto Preminger
seated together happily at a table
towards the end but there's been i from
what I understand contentious discussion
over the years with each one claiming
credit well you know we did Michael and
I went over to his house after he had a
screening and and Kirk is legendary as
we all know and he's going to turn 99 in
a month and he was spry still spry and
and wanted to exchange his thoughts and
he complimented the movie greatly he
really loved it he said he had one
one problem with it one issue and
Michael and I were bracing like oh
what's it gonna be and he said I don't
understand why the director didn't ask
me to play Kirk Douglas we met with them
before we shot we heard the story I
listened to I am Spartacus which is you
know you know his story of breaking the
blacklist and we talked to a number of
people about what happened I think what
our film tried to do with Kirk is just
completely deservedly lionize his choice
because it was crazy he put all his
money into the film he had fired a
director he didn't get along Stanley
Kubrick the studio was all over his
production company was at stake and he
says guess what I'm putting a communist
screenwriter on the on the credits and
he'd made that choice and from that
moment the water is thrown on to the
Wicked Witch that shot of Helen Mirren
as John Kennedy crosses the American
Legion picket lines and says it's a fine
film it's gonna be great that happened
that night and it was Kirk who did that
and it did mark the end however there
are stories that are also simultaneously
going on namely that Otto Preminger
actually did publicize that he was going
to put his name on Exodus though the
film came out later it was announced
earlier and so Kirk was joking with us
he said I don't know if I have the ego
to share credit with premature for this
what I like about Jay the Mo's he's very
sensitive and vulnerable and we in he
loves to have rehearsals and table reads
but then private rehearsals where we're
reading and I remember one time on
Trumbo we are in New Orleans and I'm
we're reading through and read a passage
and apparently I grimaced at some point
I don't even remember and he said what
was that and I go but he goes you know
you you had a reaction to that you know
I don't even know if you remember this
no no and and I said I did you know it
was one it was a little thing
that passes and you have an initial
knee-jerk reaction perhaps to something
and now let it go and he didn't want to
let it go no no please don't tell me
what the what was it and I had to review
it then ago um oh oh well oh it's such a
little done okay
so he pulls it out of you he wants to
know what you're thinking about what
you're feeling what what bumps you what
but what doesn't quite feel right and so
that we can talk through it to work it
out I think the thing that that I
appreciate most about Jay Roach though
is having the courage at any given point
to say I'm not sure dot dot or at this
moment I don't know there's there's so
many directors who don't know but they
never tell you that we're gonna do this
and you find out oh he didn't or she
didn't really know what they were doing
as opposed to confessing that and really
opening it up so that the collaborative
process can actually take place and and
I think I love that the most that he
welcomes the collaboration and he still
has it but and I must say it doesn't
make him a doormat he is he if he
believes in something the nice guy
starts digging his heels in and and
he'll argue his point so which I also
appreciate because you don't want a
director that you can quickly dismiss
either or um you know roughshod over he
says that just the right amount a
temperament and and the last thing I'll
say about him is that he has a
tremendous passion about the work he is
hyper focused on it and I I do an
impression of him on the set he has his
little or anything and he he waddles
from side to side and he snaps his
fingers and I know he's thinking am I
forgetting anything am I forgetting
anything little nuance and he just you
know that either but but he just
yeah that's a lot of from side to side
and snaps and just gets into a little
zone and just reviewing things and you
know it's just a pleasure so we've done
two projects together and and many more
hopefully